all of these softwares are incredibly  expensive but that doesn't mean you  can't download them today if you're a  student in any way shape or form either  university college or even high school  and have some sort of educational email  address you can sign up to basically  every single one of these for either a  free one-year trial or a free perpetual  license which basically allows you to  download install and run any of these  softwares at the same time if you're  looking at buying archicad something  that they don't advertise very often and  you have to actually dig through all of  the information  is their archicad start edition if you  want to see the full video and all  things architecture related make sure  you hit that subscribe button